Thank you your majesty for what being such a cool dude
Hey everybody, I'm sure you're screaming about that ending to the Walking Dead episode, so we'll break everything down
They did a bunch of comic book Easter eggs, and I'll try to explain
Why they probably did that ending this soon because it's relatively early in the run this season
But if you're finding me for the first time be sure to subscribe to get everything we're doing Walking Dead all season if there's new
giveaway stuff happening at the end of the video -
So largely it was a carol ezekiel episode so probably the best episode of the season so far
Largely because those are two of the best characters on the show in the show now trades on a lot of character moments like big
Ezekiel speeches and that only works when you have a really awesome
character like Ezekiel but top 10 WTF comic book Easter eggs here
We go number 10 the Ezekiel intro which is a totally mundane look at the regular life?
He leads as he's putting his
Costume on to become the king like fake it till you make it so this was a look at him getting ready for a matinee
performance
He narrated his backstory to Carol when we got one of those flashbacks
And he just talks about how he used to take care of Shiva as the zookeeper
But he also did those matinee performances
This is like him putting his makeup and his costume on getting ready to perform for a big crowd of people
Obviously it's his people, but it's still a performance fake it till you make it but number nine
I love the way they opened it with that
We are one scene and then they immediately cut to him crawling out from the pile of bodies like John snowed during Game of Thrones
They better
Thank Kit Harington for that shot when he accepts his Emmy for his performance in this week's episode
like after season six any time a character
Crawls out from a giant pile of bodies all I can think about is Jon Snow now
But it was so great just watching him, try to crawl away like he's in this moment of horror
He screams in agony
Right after doing that big long speech so the editing can sometimes get a little bit weird with the way they jump around in time
But like I said because the characters they're using in this episode are so good
It totally works, so I love the way they edited that intro number eight though was ninja Carol
I'm so happy that she's back. I hated Carol so much last season. 'I'm not gonna fight
I'm gonna hide in the cabin off by myself.' She's back in it now she
Infiltrates them and isn't it so nice that they all line up for her so that she can take them down with a couple bullets
Remember that scene from the beginning of Avengers age of Ultron where Captain America puts his shield up Thor bashes it
And they take down all those troops
Thor: Looks like they're lining up.
Captain America: Well they're excited...
Number seven was that cinematic Jerry save so one it was a really badass Jerry moment
But the way they shot it was also really awesome, too
You just see the camera as the body splits in half of that douchebag
Savior the flipside of that is I was actually wondering if they were gonna just have
Ezekiel try to stall him so that the Horde would overtake them, and he would waste all his bullets
And then Ezekiel could take him down
But it all just feeds into Ezekiel's arc like him hitting rock bottom and then getting that big call-to-action again
Although technically by the end of the episode it seems like he's hit rock bottom.... again
But number six that Ezekiel/Carol flashback where they both narrate their backstories a little bit
And if you haven't thought about them in a while they actually have relatively similar
Origin stories where they both had to choose to be the hero when given the choice
Carol had to choose to be a badass
Because her husband Ed was this abusive person
She was a totally different character at the beginning of season 1. So through circumstance through choice
They became the badasses that they are today although Ezekiel is sort of saying
I'm ready for this, so he's not quite the badass that Carol is but I'm relatively optimistic about his character
So like he says he's ready and it's pretty clear that he's not ready because he goes so crazy during the episode
But I think this is all meant to catalyze him, and we will see King Ezekiel again albeit
Just a slightly different version just because the events of this episode shook him so much
And how about all those visual metaphors of the kingdom people following him without question they're inspired by him and then
Continuing to follow him literally as walkers in death. I love the way the Savior threw that in his face
It was a great metaphor because they're in the frame the whole time as they're limping away
You can see how much it tears Ezekiel up because 1) he wants to get away from them they're walkers
They're going to try and kill him. He also mourns them because just moments ago
They were some of his best friends
But number 5 Jerry and Ezekiel versus the Kingdom walkers so Jerry has been a total badass in this episode
But it is a good call to action for Ezekiel. I think he's ready to die in this moment. He's like
This is the end I'm totally gonna die he had that a couple times during the episode just leave me here
I'm done so at every turn he tries to get the people to leave him behind
So I think he's actually kind of sad when he survives at the end of the episode but number 4 Carol
Let's the Savior's go so that she can save Ezekiel so immediately in the episode. I was like okay
This is gonna have crazy consequences
it'll weigh on Carol's soul but the turn was so great when you hear that rev from the
Motorcycle and she gives off that wry smile
'No they're not gonna get the guns...' In that you know cut to number three that big epic chase scene probably one of the best scenes
From the episode aside from the intro and what happened to Shiva at the end so for as much as people
Complained about the big action scene against the Savior's in the first episode
This is a scene that the Walking Dead does really well there aren't that many characters there aren't that many things to deal with?
She's a big stretch of abandoned road the way they shot it was great
There was epic suspense the way you think the Daryl's taken out of it
But then the camera pans out and you see him come from behind Rick's car then the funny
Indiana Jones Last Crusade
Turn at the end of the episode because you're like oh my god Rick went down with a car is he alive and you know
Just like Indiana Jones. He comes climbing off from the side, and they both look down. You look like shit
Dude, so I feel like when The Walking Dead is doing a really good job operating on all cylinders
They give you that WTF moment where you're like
Oh my god is the person that we really care about dead
And then they take it back in some funny way, so this was just their indiana jones trick that they pulled on you
But number two was actually Ezekiel returning at the end of the episode just
Really sad that he's still alive and everyone else is dead like you see all their looks on their faces like they understand
Instantly that all their loved ones the fathers the husbands they didn't come back because they're dead and of course number 1 was the death
Of Shiva, so I know everybody on Twitter, and my feed was just going crazy when this happened. Why are they doing this?
What's going on? Well one it was actually straight out of the comics
This is the way that Shiva died when she was saving Ezekiel after a failed attempt to take one of the Savior's
Bases so obviously that was the plot of this episode
So they were giving her the comic book death so if you're wondering why they killed her this early in the season
It's because they did this episode
They did the failed attack this early in the season if they would have done it later than she would have died later
But just like in the comics she dies saving him
And there's this big metaphor with Shiva's blood like he was talking about the back story when he jumped into her pen when he was
Still a zookeeper. He saw her blood and jumped to action
He saw her blood in the sewer
And we just got to say that the sewer walkers are just a special kind of gross in
There's this actual weird thing that they linger on
These hazardous material barrels a lot of people were wondering about this
Because this is relatively close to the location where they found the really melty looking Walker
What happened to this one and a bunch of people thought that it might be a tip-off for the Whisperers who cut patches of skin?
Off of dead Walker's to make Walker camo for themselves, but now because they're spending so much time hyping up this dangerous material
I'm wondering if it also has something to do with that, but let me know in the comments
What was your favorite moment from the episode or your worst moment depending on how you think about it?
I think for most people it's probably going to be the death of Shiva because she's such a cool character
And it's such a bummer for her to go this early in the season
But if she's gonna go I am happy that they gave her the comic-book death
But like I said earlier probably the best episode of the season if they can continue doing episodes like this
I feel like they can turn things around because people seem relatively disappointed with the season so far just after the last couple of episodes
So hopefully they'll turn a corner and we'll see better character work in action like this
But we got till episode 8 for the mid-season finale, but in related news
I'm doing special Justice League premiere stuff tomorrow you may have spotted the Punisher add that they played during The Walking Dead
Episode The Punisher is dropping this Friday, and the embargo is up so my non-spoilery review of season 1 will also post tomorrow
but no spoilers
It was actually a really cool season so if you really like Shane you really like the punisher all the episodes will be available on
friday
But there's a new round of the walking dead giveaway all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
And leave a comment this video congratulations to the winner from the last video Kaz Kobb
Please private message me so I can get your contact
Details you can click here for all my other Walking Dead videos
And you can click here for my Thor Ragnarok deleted scenes and alternate post credits video
Thank you so much for watching. Everybody stay awesome. I'll see you guys tonight